laplaud j'aime bien il commence à quel
âge 23 ans tu vas rester encore trois
baies normalement de rester à super ok
on attend de faire une belle avait parlé
bien 5 45 22 je sais dire ça c'est bon
je me suis dit manger avec nous a causés
mais dans un restaurant par un peu tout
et je te ment des questions et tout ça
alors j'ai les impôts j'ai les infos
jean claude van damme est revenue est
venu rendre visite aux anges à hong kong
passé parce que jean-claude vit une
partie de l'année à hong kong à la
parole embrasse fort d'ailleurs
jean-claude alors je sais canisite
jean-claude se sont vus plusieurs fois
j'ai des infos ils se sont vus à paris
et quand il est venu en septembre
dernier ils sont même allés à los
angeles tous les deux a donc ça semble
être du sérieux en tout cas ils ont une
vraie connexion à tous les deux ans la
jolie pour le clip j'ai un petit extrait
à vous montrer de jean claude van damme
dans les angles ces gens tonnes qui
donne un petit cours de karaté a virgin
sauf qu'ils lui mais des vrais coûts est
un peu en place
il ya un problème c'est vrai que d'après
tu vois il regarde ce qui se passe quand
les puissants des gens pas prêts de
trois coups de pied que même si il me
protège bien ça peu après alors fois ça
peut commencer à faire du mal on a eu
tendance à baisser la garde
mais maintenant c'est comment je fais
c'est des coups de pieds comme ceux ci
sont sans effets sonores et personne ne
voit ça la personne qui voit ça parce
que les blocs a raté tout ce qu'ils font
tu perdes tam comme ça tu peux doubler
tout et ça c'est la merde avec hautbois
chaos quand il sera parfois il fait pas
on dit c est vraiment ça ça 15 au point
même où tu peux doubler
oui et je fais pas tu sens un peu comme
ça eloi super bon moi j'ai fait une
émission avec des cahiers ya longtemps
il y avait vent d'avis a cogné meba il
m'a défoncé mais on l'a d'or mais moi
mais moi je sais mais c'est vrai que
j'ai élu et il lui met des ministres
nicole le mec il est tenace
oui mais quand il était venu sur le
plateau ici il avait comme chauffer
grave une chroniqueuse francesca pris
son numéro
c'est un séducteur et c'est pour ça
qu'on lève mail apparemment je vous dis
là une vraie rencontre à nice à lui et
il est belge il débloque moi j'aime bien
brasser moi moi sur ce que je mange pas
de ce pain là mais ça aurait été ma
canne